denn was genau ist dann spanien passiert
ja wie du schon gesagt hast gestern
breaking news der alte könig juan carlos
hat seinem sohn dem an tieren und könig
verliebt mit den sechs mitgeteilt dass
das land verlassen wird das ist der
offizielle grund wieder schon gesagt
dass es sind wohl die ermittlungen die
das oberste gericht in madrid
eingeleitet hat es geht um
schmiergeldzahlungen
es geht zurück auf das jahr 2008 da
wurde in saudi arabien eine
schnellbahnstrecke gebaut und angeblich
hat dort hohen carlos ein spanisches
konsortium hin vermittelt und dafür 90
bis 100 millionen dollar an schmiergeld
kassiert die offenbar in der schweiz
sehen wenn du jetzt aber fragt was der
inoffizielle grund ist sieht sowohl aus
dass sein sohn verliebte ihn dazu
gedrängt hat nun das land zu verlassen
das ist natürlich in einer von mir ein
hammer eigentlich so was zu tun weiß man
wo der könig der ehemalige könig jetzt
hin ist ja das hört sich an wie ein
krimi offenbar ist alles perfekt geplant
gewesen er soll gestern das land mit
einem segelboot verlassen haben in
galicien ist dann offenbar weiter nach
portugal gereist dort in porto in ein
flugzeug gestiegen und dann in die
dominikanische republik nach santo
domingo geflogen und von dort aus so
sieht es nach unseren recherchen und
recherchen anderer zeitung aus ist er
wohl weiter nach la romana das ist eine
küstenstadt auf der insel unter 20.000
einwohner und dort gibt es ein luxus
domizil in hotels oder das freundin von
ihm gehört und einer das sind vier
brüder an der spitze pepe einer der
besten freunde des königs das sind vier
brüder die milliarden mit zucker gemacht
haben und schon seit langen jahren an
der seite des königs stehen und offenbar
ist er dort untergetaucht aber ist
alleinige reißt seine frau sofia dabei
wiegen wie verläuft es jetzt weiter mit
dem familienleben wenn man es so nennen
kann ja also das familien dem man muss
dazu wissen 2014 ist der yuan carlos
abgedankt übrigens auch auf drängen der
familie
oder seines sohnes der dann den posten
übernommen hat weil es ja damals diese
affäre gab mit dieser deutschen corinna
von sayn-wittgenstein aus rät in dem
jahr wo eigentlich die goldene hochzeit
mit seiner eigentlichen frau sophia von
griechenland an stand das wir wissen es
sophia hat gesagt ich werde das land
nicht mit ihm verlassen sie wird im
spanischen königshaus weiter bleiben was
man dazu sagen kann ist dass er so viel
also seine ehefrau sich vor jahren von
ihm entfernt hat sie machen nur noch
offiziellen auftritt und wie zum
beispiel anfang des jahres als die
schwester von juan carlos gestorben ist
ansonsten gilt eigentlich diese ehe
quasi im ruhestand also quasi
heruntergefahren
wir haben jetzt die spanier darauf
reagiert ja also diese nachricht sorgt
schon für viel bewegung und ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl wenn man das jetzt
alles so verfolgt das ist das ist da
zwei lager gibt es zum einen gibt es die
die sagen ja das ist ein notwendiger
schritt
dieser könig hat nicht viel gutes für
das land durch seine affären sei es
hinsichtlich des schmiergeldes auf der
anderen seite auch durch seine affären
mit anderen frauen getan
aber natürlich gibt es auf der anderen
seite noch viele spanier die dankbar
sind man muss dazu wissen er ist ja
wirklich einer der wenigen monaten die
wirklich auch noch sein land aktiv als
könig regiert haben 1970 und viele
spanier sind dafür dankbar dass er
damals das land aus der franco diktatur
in die parlamentarische monarchie und
quasi in die demokratischen anfängen des
landes geführt hat und das vergessen ihm
viele nicht